Hi, I'm Sumit Gulwani.
I lead a research and engineering team
that develops APIs for programming-by-examples.
These APIs are used inside various
Microsoft products including Excel,
PowerShell, and OMS.
Today, I am going to show you a demo of these APIs
in the content of a data preparation and analysis task.
Consider this text file that contains 911 call records.
At the top, there is some metadata
and then there is a header row
and then each line contains a single
911 call record entry
whose various fields are separated by the pipe character.
Suppose I want to answer questions such as
'When are vehicular accidents most common?'
As in, which hour of the week?
Is it Fridays at 5 PM or Wednesdays at 4 PM?
To answer such questions, we will need to
extract various fields from these records.
In particular, we will need to extract this date
and map it to the corresponding weekday.
In this case, this is Friday.
We will need to extract the time and
map it to the corresponding hour bracket.
In this case, this is 1 PM.
And then we will need to filter the rows
that correspond to vehicular accidents.
So we gave this task to Python programmers in a user study
and it took 30 minutes on average
to do this task.
Now I can do this task in 30 seconds
using our APIs.
This 10 to 100 productivity increase
is very useful for data scientists
who end up spending 80 percent of their time wrangling data.
Even more interestingly, I can do this task
without writing a single line of code.
This is very significant since 99 percent
of computer users do not know programming.
And this kind of investment can bring
programming to the masses.
The underlying technology is called program synthesis
or programming-by-examples.
This is a new frontier in AI where the
computer programs itself.
The user simply provides input/output examples
or in some cases, simply points to the input data.
And the tool comes up with an indented program
for automating the task.
These programs can be synthesized
in different programming languages such as C#,
Python, or R.
Now you can watch the demo that I am going to show you
by wearing one of two hats.
Either you are an end user who would like to
leverage these technologies for your data preparation task
or you are a product developer
who would like to leverage the underlying APIs
to develop such distinguished features for your own product
and bring the program synthesis innovation to your customers.
Now the first step in analyzing this file
would be to ingest it into a tabular format
tools like Excel, Power BI,
and SSIS allow you to do this
by specifying the various parameters such as
what is a row delimiter?
What is a column delimiter?
How many lines to skip from the top?
whether or not there is a header row.
Our data wrangling tool also allows you to
do this by specifying various parameters.
But when I point this tool to the file
then it automatically analyzes
the patterns in this file and is able to
automatically infer the various parameters.
Such as
the column delimiter, which in this case is a custom
separator, which is the pipe character. The fact
that there are column headers, the file encoding
utf-16 and the fact that there
are 10 lines to be skipped at the top.
Now more generally, whenever you have a rich UI
inside any product, you can ask the question
Where the program synthesis APIs
can be used to automatically predict the
various parameters in that UI.
Either by analyzing the underlying data
or from the past user actions.
So in this case, our file ingestion API
is able to infer the parameters in the UI
by simply analyzing the patterns in the file.
And when I hit finish
the inferred metadata is used to parse the file.
Now let me get rid of the columns that I do not need
and let's look at this description column.
It contains various soft fields that I am interested in
such as date and time.
Splitting this long string into the various constraining
fields is not easy
because there are multiple delimiters such as the
hyphen character, the @ character
the semicolon character
and even more challenging is the fact that not all
occurrences of hyphens are delimiters, such as the ones
that occur inside the date.
Now in order to split such a string
into various constraining fields, we have developed an API
to split columns by example.
Now when I invoke this API it also tries
to behave predictively.
Meaning it first tries to split the column
without any examples and then I can
provide the examples at the places where it got it wrong.
So in this case, it extracted the
first column correctly and the second column correctly
but in the third column, there are some
errors in row three
and row twenty-one and so on.
So now manually browsing for such errors
can also be quite tedious, especially when the dataset
is large and the errors do not occur in your viewport.
So when I go to the advanced mode
the interactive version of this API
actually points out all the six different formats that
occur in the dataset
and I can quickly inspect the output on the six formats
to identify where the errors are.
And in this case, I give an example
to fix the time column
and when I hit the apply button
the tool tries to learn a program
which is consistent with the example that I provided.
And then when I hit okay
the tool executes this program on the rest of the dataset
to produce the intended splitting.
Now the next step in this task
is to do some transformations
such as map the date
to the corresponding weekday.
Now I can do this using the
Derive Column by Example capability that we have developed
and all that I need to do is to give an example of
the transformation that I want to do.
So when I type Friday for this corresponding date
know that the autocomplete feature of the tool
already provides me with the
completed example
and when I hit enter the tool tries to learn a program
which is consistent with the example that I provided.
So I will hit okay to accept the changes.
Now if you look on the right side the tool has started building
the entire script as a series of steps.
If I hover over this last step that I did
the tool actually shows me what kind of
transformation it inferred. So in particular it says
that the transformation is to extract the day
of the week from the date time.
So now we would like to map the time column
to the corresponding bucket
and I can again do this
by giving an example.
So suppose I want to map it to the
corresponding half an hour bucket
all that I would do is to give an example.
For those of you who are familiar with the flash fill feature
in Microsoft Excel, this capability
is much more advanced than that since this can manipulate
dates, numbers, times.
Now instead of the half an hour bucket
suppose I want to map it to the corresponding two hour bucket.
Again I can do this
by means of simply providing an example.
Now just imagine how much effort would it be
if you were to do this by writing a program yourself.
But in this case I simply wanted the corresponding hour.
So 1 PM suffices for me here
and the system is able to learn the transformation
with again one example.
Now initially I promised you that I would be able
to do this demo in 30 seconds
but I have gone much more than that.
So turns out that all these transformations that I did
I didn't really need to do them.
I was doing them just to show you the various capabilities.
So if you recall, within 10 seconds
I was at this screen where I was able to automatically ingest
the file into a tabular format
and then this description column contains
the relevant fields that I am interested in.
If all that I wanted to do was to map it
to the corresponding week hour
I can do that simply by giving an example
instead of having to split it
into the various constraining fields.
And now the last step in the demo
is to filter the rows in the dataset
to those that correspond to vehicular accident.
I can do that by invoking the
filter column feature.
And maybe I want to use a predicate which says
ends with vehicular accident.
The moment I type 'v'
the autocomplete variations pop up
and it not only avoids me
having to type multiple keystrokes but you can also
see that it tells me what percentage of the rows would match if I were to pick
a certain edition.
But most significantly it shows me
that I was about to do a wrong computation
without probably even realizing it
because there are certain rows in the dataset that end with vehicular accident
without a hyphen.
Now if you are a
Python programmer and you did not notice this thing
you could have computed the wrong result without realizing it.
So instead what I want to use is the predicate
which says contains vehicular accident as opposed to
ends with vehicular accident.
And when I do that the system then ends up
filtering the rows to the
ones that correspond to vehicular accident.
And all that I have to do now is to simply count
the number of different week hours here.
And now we notice that most vehicular accidents
happen on Thursdays at 5 PM
and in the rush hour traffic of the Wednesdays are the worst hour.
So you see in 30 seconds you are able to draw
some very good insights from this data
and now you know when to avoid driving.
If you want to do this demo yourself
send me email.
Also the underlying APIs
are hosted on GitHub with appropriate documentation and samples.
If you would like to use these APIs
inside your own product please get in touch
and we would love to engage with you. Thank you.